[MUSIC PLAYING]
It's a little bit
more complicated.
And you've got--
Regents' Professor of
hydrology and water resources,
Hoshin Gupta, is interested
in a deeper understanding
of scientific models--
all the facts and
things we understand
about how the world works.
How do we take
conceptual ideas--
theories about how
the world works--
and data that we collect
from the world, and put them
together to build models, which
we can then use for prediction
or decision making.
Or actually, my
interest is more in how
we use those models
to help further
enhance the learning
process, how we
understand the world around us.
I think students-- it
usually takes students
about half a term to realize
that the subject material is
only a reason to be
talking, and that it really
has to do with more universal
ideas of science, and analysis,
and insight, and creativity.
There tends to be
this sort of idea
that if you build a
model based on physics
and physically-based
principles, that such models are
superior to models that
are built based primarily
on looking for patterns in data.
And of course, in
today's world, there
tends to be a lot,
lot more data.
And we're finding that our ideas
about how the world works--
which are based in
ideas about physics--
don't necessarily agree
with what the data tells us.
Gupta was born in India,
attended Case Western
University for his doctorate,
and in 1983, followed
his professor to the U of
A Hydrology Department.
It just so happened that
the major professors who
were involved in water resources
happened to be in the systems
department.
That gave me the opportunity
to actually start
studying systems theory
as a foundational concept,
as opposed hydrology
or civil engineering
as a foundational basis.
Gupta sees little distinction
between research and teaching.
In addition to his
research, he teaches
classes in modeling
fundamentals,
and an earth sciences course
for non-science majors.
I don't think you can do
research without help.
For that, you need
students and other people.
And you can't get those
people to the point
that they can assist
you in your research
without doing teaching.
So I think of teaching as more
of a mentoring process, really.
It's helping students to
acquire the kind of information
that they need in order to
be able to then contribute
to the scientific endeavor.
He cares about the way you learn
as much as he cares about what
you're learning, so that
when he's teaching it to you,
you really understand
the point and not just,
OK, I can solve this problem,
or I can get the right number.
It's not really about
the right number
as much as it is about
the process of learning.
Growing up in India, he
was a skilled sailor,
competing in
international competition.
Today, he has a variety
of other interests,
but keeps coming back
to his love of music.
Much to my wife's chagrin, I
don't play the guitar very much
anymore.
And I now play drums.
And I play drums in
three different bands.
I tend to think that
there's a tendency
in our current
educational system
to make a strong wall
between physical sciences
and the social sciences.
And the longer I'm involved
in this profession,
the less useful I think that is.